[Music]
century of teaching millions of American
boys marksmanship and woodcraft
patriotism good citizenship the Boy
Scouts of America have decided to change
completely starting with their name it
is now the scouts its gender-neutral
Mike Rowe was an Eagle Scout he went on
to host dirty jobs and someone's got to
do it he now hosts Facebook's number-one
show it's called returning the favor we
spoke to him recently Mike Rowe thanks a
lot for joining us
you were famously an Eagle Scout as a
boy the scouts are no longer the Boy
Scouts but simply the scouts what what's
your response to that well it's funny
you should ask Tucker because no less
than 10,000 people have asked me that
very question over the last month my
facebook page distinguished Eagle Scout
if you're keeping score five or six
years ago I was I was awarded that and
it was very touching and look I'm
watching what's happening carefully I've
sent 50 to 55 thousand letters out over
the last ten years to other Eagle Scouts
and I think the country needs the scouts
I think the country needs the Future
Farmers of America and SkillsUSA and 4-h
desperately now more than ever so it
does it does concern me to see all the
confusion swirling around the
organization but like like so many
wounds I'm afraid many of these are are
self-inflicted and I also think that
some of the confusion that's going on is
legitimate I read their official
statement while girls are being welcomed
in I didn't read anything about
integrated camping trips or were troop
meetings I think it really is a play to
compete more directly with the Girl
Scouts and I understand why the Girl
Scouts are upset but since when is
competition a bad thing so I think you
know character development and
leadership development have never been
more important than they are today so my
hope is that the Boy Scouts assume the
opportunity that's presenting itself and
become an antidote for the safe space
environment that's out there and pushed
back a little
but I mean not to sound like the angry
guy on your neighbor's porch yelling at
the kids on the lawn but when I was in
the scouts and 74 and 75 it wasn't a
safe space there in the basement of our
church I mean you'd go home with the
bloody nose sometimes or a black eye
yeah a boxing ring you know it was a it
was a vibrant place where you really
could test yourself and fail in a way
that on the one hand made you safe
enough to attempt but on the other hand
didn't try and check every box and
please every single person that's it's
it's it's a tough time you know I'm
sympathetic for the leaders but I'm
afraid you've got to draw the line
somewhere and be very very clear about
what you stand for as well as against so
you don't see this as the end of
something then I don't know you know I
mean again I you either evolve or you or
you die but at the same time I think
people are confused because the scouts
simply haven't come out and said
categorically what they're for right so
I just think this conversation touches
on every single hot point right now
going on in popular culture from
tolerance to acceptance which by the way
I'm not sure what the difference between
those two things is anymore but there
used to be a big difference people are
struggling for their own identity and
look the last time I was on we talked
about this we we talked about the idea
that everything is either being informed
by a safe space culture or everything is
being informed by people who want to be
challenged I think people are desperate
to be challenged and my hope for these
youth based organizations that help
preach character is that they look for
people who want to be challenged and I
and not curry favor so much with those
who want a nice reassuring pat on the
head yeah that's how the Episcopal
Church does happen great to see you
thank you for that that was really smart
be prepared anytime